I want to show you a very funny short
clip of Republican senator Marco Rubio
Rubio appeared on Fox news last night
after Joe Biden's State of the Union
Address and it is so funny what Rubio
says I'm not even going to tease it for
you okay let's just play it and then we
will discuss you didn't hear a lot of
talk about pregnant men tonight you
didn't hear a lot of talk about some of
these crazy things because they're
pivoting now to an election mode and
they know all that stuff is toxic so try
and pretend it's not happening but it
remains at the core and at the heart of
their Administration not a lot of woke
talk tonight except for the climate
stuff which by the way he doesn't tell
you benefits China
Marco Rubio realizing in real time Joe
Biden didn't talk about pregnant men Joe
Biden didn't talk about woke stuff he
says it's because they're pivot pivoting
to election mode the reality is Joe
Biden never was talking about this stuff
and in fact these are very small issues
on the Democratic side on the left in
the Democratic party I will not deny for
a second
that if you spend a lot of time on
Twitter or Reddit you might see a whole
bunch of stuff about
wokeness and so-called pregnant men and
all of these things I don't deny that
you might see that if you spend a lot of
time on these platforms but if you spend
a lot of time on those on those
platforms you would have been one of the
people in 2020 who thought that Bernie
had the nomination wrapped up and that
there was no interest in Joe Biden being
the nominee and as I told you then as
and as I will repeat now
the discussions that dominate some of
these online spheres are not actually
the issues of Greater concern to the
vast majority of the democratic party
nor of the constituents of the
democratic party either and there was a
reason that you didn't hear a lot about
woke uh sorry about pregnant men last
night which is it's not actually an
issue that is at the Forefront of the
minds of almost anyone on the left I
would actually go even further
part of the reason that those sorts of
things even come up at all are because
the right has abandoned policy and only
wants to talk about that sort of thing
it is because the right brings forward
issues of they're putting cat litter
boxes for furries who are studio for
people who think they're animals are
they even know how to define furry
um but that's not a real story but it is
the right that creates the story it's
the writer who says they want double
mastectomies for prepubescent girls wait
a second
do they have breasts if they're
prepubescent that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever it's the right that is
crowbarring a lot of these issues in
none of this stuff has ever been at the
heart of the democratic party and this
is why looking at Twitter
isn't super useful to figure out what's
going on in the US overall and what's
going on within the Democratic party
maybe Marco Rubio is realizing that if
you want to see this clip it's on our
YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show